We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. My friend Julia Barton, that's me, is in a New York City apartment with Michael Eidov. My name is Michael Eidov,
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球知名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州及全球各地合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这都是该大学促进所有生物生活质量的使命的一部分。请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu 了解更多信息。这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。我的朋友茱莉亚·巴顿，也就是我，正和迈克尔·埃多夫一起在纽约市的一间公寓里。我叫迈克尔·埃多夫，
and I'm the editor of Made in Russia, unsung icons of Soviet design. And Florence, a parrot that sounds exactly like the building's door buzzer. And no matter how hard we try, WAHHA! THE NORN! To cut out Lawrence. His door buzzer imitation cannot be denied. But maybe that's okay, because Adolf's new book on Soviet design is an homage
我是《俄罗斯制造：苏联设计的无名偶像》一书的编辑。还有弗洛伦斯，一只学得和这栋楼门铃一模一样的鹦鹉。不管我们怎么努力，哇哈！诺恩！想要阻止劳伦斯。它模仿门铃的声音实在让人无法忽视。但也许这没关系，因为阿道夫关于苏联设计的新书是对
to the stuff of ordinary Soviet life. Cigarettes, drinking glasses, subway token machines, Soviet design is an homage to the stuff of ordinary Soviet life. Cigarettes, drinking glasses, subway token machines, and it might be hard for outsiders to see what this seemingly random collection of Soviet consumer goods have in common. But I don't believe there's something that unites them all. To define this aesthetic, you first need to realize that most of these items were rip offs of Western sources, you know, ovarian qualities. They are imitations. Like the way Lawrence the parrot is imitating the door
普通苏联生活物品的致敬。香烟、酒杯、地铁票售票机，苏联设计是对普通苏联生活物品的致敬。香烟、酒杯、地铁票售票机，外人可能很难看出这堆看似随意的苏联消费品有什么共同点。但我认为确实有某种东西将它们联系在一起。要定义这种美学，你首先需要意识到，其中大多数物品都是对西方来源的抄袭，你知道，就是那种山寨品质。它们是模仿。就像鹦鹉劳伦斯模仿门
buzzer. Shut up, Lawrence. One look at the items in this book, even though they are shameless imitations, you'll see that the Soviet stuff is unmistakably Soviet. Take your Soviet soda machine. In those, carbonated drinks came not in bottles, but straight into a communal drinking glass, something chained to the machine. And the excruciating Soviet arcade games were designed by the Committee on Amusement. Most Americans haven't even seen these artifacts, but in a way, we're responsible for them.
铃一样。闭嘴，劳伦斯。看看这本书里的物品，尽管它们是毫无廉耻的模仿，但你会发现这些苏联物品带有鲜明的苏联特色。以你们的苏联苏打水机为例。在那里面，碳酸饮料不是装在瓶子里，而是直接流入一个公共饮水杯中，这个杯子是用链条拴在机器上的。而那些痛苦不堪的苏联街机游戏是由游乐委员会设计的。大多数美国人甚至没见过这些文物，但在某种程度上，我们要为它们负责。
Basically, it all goes back to the kitchen debates. In 1959, there was this wildly successful American exhibit in Moscow. It's the official opening of the American Exposition, counterpart of the Soviet trade show in New York, and dedicated to showcasing the highest candidate of life in our country. Vice President Nixon showed Soviet premier Nikita Krushcheva
基本上，这一切都可以追溯到厨房辩论。1959年，美国在莫斯科举办了一场轰动一时的展览。这是美国博览会的正式开幕，也是苏联在纽约贸易展的对等展览，旨在展示我国最高的生活标准。副总统尼克松带着苏联总理尼基塔·赫鲁晓夫
around the exhibit and they stopped in front of a model suburban home to address an audience before new American color TV cameras. There are some instances where you may be ahead of us. For example, in the development of your of the thrust of your rockets for the investigation about our space. There may be some instances, for example, color television, where we're ahead of you. But in order for both of us, for both of us, you, for both of us, that better.
参观了展览，他们在美式彩色电视摄像机前的一座样板郊区住宅前停下来向观众讲话。在某些情况下，你们可能领先于我们。例如，在开发用于太空探测火箭推力方面。在某些情况下，例如彩色电视，我们可能领先于你们。但为了我们双方，为了我们双方，为了我们双方，那更好。
You never could see it any better. Michael Aydov says that despite Krushchev's bombast and the recent success of Sputnik, the Soviets were humiliated by all of America's stuff. Krishov decided the Soviet people needed stuff too, but it was a huge struggle for the Communist Party to switch Soviet factories from producing tanks and rockets to cassette decks and hair dryers. Usually the way it worked was, you know, some party guy would come back from a foreign trip and bring in a German radio and give it to the
你永远看不出它有什么好。迈克尔·埃多夫说，尽管赫鲁晓夫大放厥词，加之苏联人造卫星最近发射成功，但苏联人还是被美国所有的东西羞辱了。赫鲁晓夫决定苏联人民也需要这些东西，但对于共产党来说，要将苏联工厂从生产坦克和火箭转向生产盒式录音机和吹风机，是一场巨大的斗争。通常的做法是，你知道，某个党内官员从国外旅行回来，带回一台德国收音机，把它交给
engineers and say make one like it. And then they would just reverse engineer it and then they would look around for the guy who draws well and they're like, all right, well, can you draw? Okay, you do the logo and that would be the logo that would last for the next 40 years. The system produced a lot of strange stuff, but sometimes the Soviets did better than the original. Take the unbelievably cool magazine, Krugerzor. No, everybody should just bow down to further glory of Krugerzor. It was supposedly based on something Krugerzshev saw while in the United States, a magazine with a record in it.
工程师，然后说“造一个一样的”。然后他们就会对其进行逆向工程，接着四处寻找擅长画画的人，对他说：“行吧，你会画画吗？好，你来做这个标志。”而这个标志就会使用长达40年。这个系统生产了很多奇怪的东西，但有时苏联人做出的东西比原版还要好。以那本酷得难以置信的杂志《克罗科佐尔》为例。不，每个人都应该向《克罗科佐尔》的辉煌顶礼膜拜。它据说源于赫鲁晓夫在美国时看到的东西，一本内含唱片的杂志。
I'd of course, it it the original podcast. It actually sounds like public radio. There would be an article in the magazine and then the contents of the vinyl disk would somehow illustrate the article. You know, there would be the sounds of the forest or something like that, or folk songs of some far-flung tribe. Or this. What started happening over time was, you know, since the people who made this magazine had access to something, you know, unbelievably awesome for the Civic Union, which is, you know, since the people who made this magazine had access to something, you know, unbelievably awesome for the Civic Union, which is, you know, a vinyl of press.
当然，这是最初的播客。它听起来确实像公共广播。杂志里会有一篇文章，然后黑胶唱片的内容会以某种方式诠释这篇文章。你知道，会有森林的声音之类的内容，或者某个遥远部落的民歌。或者这个。随着时间推移，发生的事情是，你知道，既然制作这本杂志的人能够接触到一些东西，你知道，对于苏维埃联盟来说，这是难以置信的了不起的东西，你知道的，既然制作这本杂志的人能够接触到一些东西，对于苏维埃联盟来说是难以置信的了不起的东西，那就是，你知道的，一台黑胶压制机。
They started slipping in a little pop music in there. It was the round tearout discs in Kruvazor that gave Russians their first non-bootleg recordings of everyone from Barbra Streisand to Pink Floyd to Michael Jackson. The main thing that unites the designs in Made in Russia is that they're often the only designs. Michael I'd often pick from shelf loads of, say, different cassette recorders. Most Soviets had one, the Vistina.
他们开始在里面偷偷塞进一点流行音乐。《克罗科佐尔》里的可撕式圆盘唱片，让俄罗斯人第一次听到了从芭芭拉·史翠珊、平克·弗洛伊德到迈克尔·杰克逊等各种非盗版录音。凝聚《俄罗斯制造》中各种设计的主要因素是，它们通常是仅有的设计。迈克尔·埃多夫经常从满架子的、比方说不同的盒式录音机中进行选择。大多数苏联人都有一个，那就是“维斯京娜”。
In the BK Electronic Up Personal Computer, probably made Russian speaking hackers the best in the world through its sheer awfulness. Nobody had any other choice. Farbeid for me to suggest that this is actually a good thing, but it certainly simplifies getting to know one another because if you grew up in the Soviet Union and you're my age or older, I already know so much about you. Including the song that put you to bed at night. You know if you grew up in the Soviet Union, it's just seared into your brain. I can sing it for you if you want. How does it go?
至于BK电子个人电脑，可能凭借其纯粹的糟糕程度，让说俄语的黑客成为了世界上最厉害的黑客。没有人有其他选择。我可不敢说这其实是一件好事，但它确实让彼此的了解变得简单了，因为如果你在苏联长大，而且和我年龄相仿或更大，我对你已经了解得太多了。包括那首伴你入眠的歌。你知道的，如果你在苏联长大，这首歌已经深深烙印在你的脑海里。如果你想听，我可以为你唱。它是怎么唱的来着？
I think it goes. This theme from a children's puppet show aired every night at 815 on Soviet television. You can't really call the crude animal puppets, icons of Soviet design, but I don't put them in his book anyway. Because with their bright eyes and worn out for, Krusha the Pig and Stepashka the Bunny represent a lost universe. 11 time zones, closed off from the rest of the world, making their own stuff in their own way. The tired toys are sleeping now.
我想它是这样的。这是每晚8点15分在苏联电视上播出的儿童木偶剧的主题曲。你不能真把那些粗糙的动物木偶称为苏联设计的偶像，但无论如何我还是把它们收录进了他的书里。因为带着明亮的眼睛和磨损的毛皮，小猪克罗沙和兔子斯特帕什卡代表了一个失落的宇宙。11个时区，与世隔绝，用他们自己的方式制造他们自己的东西。疲惫的玩具现在睡着了。
That's how the song goes. Good night, Roman. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Julia Barton, one of the great radio reporters and editors. She's also part of the Oberlin College public radio conspiracy. She edited a few of my pieces when I did some stuff for a week in America and I swear every single piece I've done since then has been better because of my contact with her. No kidding. You can find her at juliabarton.com.
歌词就是这样的。晚安，罗曼。《99%隐形》本周由杰出的广播记者兼编辑茱莉亚·巴顿制作。她也是欧柏林学院公共广播阴谋集团的一员。当我为“美国一周”做一些节目时，她编辑了我的一些作品，我敢发誓，从那以后我做的每一篇作品都因为与她的接触而变得更好。真的。你可以在 juliabarton.com 找到她。
It was also produced by me, Roman Mars. You can find me right here all the time. Tell my kids I love them. This program is made possible with support from Lunar, making a difference with creativity. It's a project of KALW 91.7 local public radio in San Francisco, the American Institute of Architect San Francisco in the Center for Architecture and Design. To find a link to Michael Eidoff's made in Russia, unsung icons of Soviet design are very fine book if I do say so myself,
它也是由我，罗曼·马斯制作的。你随时都可以在这里找到我。告诉我的孩子们我爱他们。本程序由 Lunar 赞助播出，通过创意创造不同。这是旧金山 KALW 91.7 本地公共广播电台的项目，由美国建筑师学会旧金山分会以及建筑与设计中心联合呈现。要找到迈克尔·埃多夫的《俄罗斯制造：苏联设计的无名偶像》的链接，如果我要自己说的话，这是一本非常棒的书，
or just if you want to look at some pics of cool Soviet catch, go to 99%invisible.org. Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Бай, Bye, you boy. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者如果你只是想看一些酷炫苏联好玩物品的照片，请访问 99%invisible.org。拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜托，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜托，拜托，拜托！这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。